maybe the most important thing to keep
in mind when you're using GPT is what
the system is doing and what it's not
GPT is not giving you the answer
remember going back to what all the
history of AI it's an inference gbt
doesn't actually know anything right
there's no answer to be had it's like
you know the the 1 2 3 4 FS or the
handwriting recognition which there's no
AR typle thing but it's making an
inference of what it could be what this
could be gbt is giving you what it
thinks a correct answer looks like it's
not the thing itself it's not the answer
it's a similar it's a reflection it's an
inference it's like it's like looking
through two stages of a mirror it's what
it thinks it predicts the right answer
resembles